foreign
YouTube video on the YouTube channel of
Simply learn in today's video we are
going to be talking about Instagram
advertising and Instagram reels what is
it what do you need to know about um
what ads are available Instagram how can
you optimize these ads for maximum
performance and how can you use
Instagram reels to grow your following
even further now I am Mark campman I'm
your digital navigator for this video
but before we start if you like this
video click the like button and if you
want to join our learner community on
YouTube subscribe to our Channel by
clicking on the link below so are you
ready let me start with giving you some
interesting Instagram stats that will
show you that Instagram has to be part
of your digital marketing strategy now
Instagram is only 12 year olds it is now
the seventh most visited website in the
world yes listen to this it's the
seventh most visited website in the
world and it is the um fourth most used
social media platform by monthly active
users
1.22 billion users every month their
nines Instagram is ninth on the Google's
most searched terms list it's the second
most downloaded app in the world on the
uh the app stores and Instagram is most
popular amongst the Gen Z population
generation Zed Generation X males are
the fastest growing demographic yep and
that takes Instagram into a B2B into a
business world as well India has the
most number of Instagram users in the
world and people spend more time on the
Instagram stories than in the Instagram
news feed telling you a lot about the
importance of stories these days and
Instagram stories ads they generate
about 25 of Instagram's advertising
Revenue now do you need any more facts
to convince you that Instagram is one of
the most popular social media networks
and that it has to be part of your
digital marketing strategy so let's dive
a bit deeper into the Instagram
advertising opportunities and the reels
that you can use in Instagram so in this
session we are going to be talking about
Instagram ads in digital marketing why
is it so important what are the benefits
that you can get from Instagram ads
we're then going to look at the
different types of Instagram ads that to
you that you have available I'm going to
show you some Instagram ad Types on
Instagram and I'm also going to show you
where on Facebook you can go to create
to create the Instagram ads we're then
going to dig into the Instagram reels
yeah it's a new feature about two years
ago it is kind of the um the the
follow-up from igtv it is Instagram's
response to tick tock success you have
an Instagram reels are short vertical
videos that are very powerful in the um
and and used by many people these days
so we're going to dive into this we're
going to see the benefits that you can
get as a business for them and I'm going
to show you quickly where to go on
Instagram to set up these these
Instagram reels I'm then going to give
you a few tips on the Instagram reels
and then we're going to close off
today's session with some frequently
asked questions that I'm getting a lot
in the when it comes to Instagram
advertising and Instagram reels so are
you ready for this let's get started
let's look at Instagram ads in digital
marketing so let's talk about Instagram
ads and branding first why is it so
important important to use Instagram
advertising for your branding well more
than 25 billion businesses use Instagram
to promote their services and products
yeah so when they are all working on
developing their brand through Instagram
so 90 of the Instagram accounts they
follow at least one business on
Instagram and 62 percent of users say
that they are more interested in a brand
after seeing them in an Instagram story
so it's a very important platform for
Brands to connect with their users yeah
when many Instagram users they actually
use Instagram to research new products
and services and most Instagram users
almost more than 80 percent they say
they take an action after seeing a
product on Instagram
yes so no surprise that many brands are
active on Instagram yeah and on average
you can say that the brands do about one
and a half times posting every day yeah
so there's no doubt that Instagram
should be part of your business yeah it
is an effective tool for advertisers to
boost brand awareness and increase
engagement with their followers and
their customers and it's not only a
platform to Showcase your brand but also
a channel through which you can interact
with your followers and build customer
loyalty and then I'm not even talking
yet about the e-commerce opportunities
you have on Instagram by opening up a
shop by promoting your products on
Instagram so a platform where you
definitely have to be
so it can act as a new channel for your
business which can extend your online
presence
and when you are on Instagram you can
promote you can sell you can increase
sales of your business and you can gain
many many benefits from being on
Instagram and here are just a few of
them so you can keep up with what's
happening in the world so if many people
if everyone yeah billions of people are
on Instagram why aren't you so there is
the new Instagram shop feature that can
help you and your brand to get more
sales so you can open up a shop on
Facebook you can then connect that shop
with your Instagram and you can promote
your products you can tag your products
in your Instagram posts and that will
lead
two sales through your um your Facebook
and your e-commerce shop it's fantastic
for competitor analysis what are your
competitors doing on Instagram what are
they promoting what are they advertising
you can learn a lot about what works and
what doesn't work in the the market
Instagram is also a place where you can
connect with your customers where you
can deliver customer service yeah so
it's not just offline or not just on
Twitter but you can use that on
Instagram as well
so
Instagram these days is a very normal a
very basic platforms and it's almost
like you're having your website
customers expect you to be on Instagram
as well these days so if you do that
properly it can help you in getting more
customers growing your online customer
base on Instagram and it can help you in
developing your brand to generate more
sales and to grow your online reputation
by setting the tone and the style of
your posts you can immediately develop
and present an online sort of identity
that you can then transfer into your
online reputation
another powerful aspect of that you have
with Instagram is that you can work with
influencers yeah there's many
influencers many Instagram
users with large followings they offer
their services to Brands to help them in
promoting their products and services
so that is not enough for you finally
yeah the virality on Instagram is very
very strong so if you have good content
good posts good stories Good reels you
can go very high and wide and far
through the uh the Instagram
um the Instagram world and many people
will view your videos and share your
videos so it's a platform you can no
longer ignore and you definitely want to
be there
so in 2020 a new style of post was
created which was called the Instagram
reels which is kind of the follow-up of
the igtv which was a kind of a vertical
video kind of YouTube channel that you
could get on on Instagram now it is sort
of a response of Instagram to the growth
of uh of tick tock and creators on
Instagram like Justin Bieber lizzo
Stanley Tucci they really helped to
transform this
um feature from a almost like a tick
tock wannabe to a full-blown competitor
of tiktok they are full screen vertical
videos that can be up to 90 seconds long
yeah they come with many unique editing
tools and an extensive library of audio
tracks as well so it's very easy to make
these short videos and to start sharing
them and you will see that the fuse and
the engagement that you get with these
reels in Instagram is extremely high on
top of the sound real can include
multiple video clips filters captors and
in an interactive backgrounds so you can
add stickers all the tools that you
expect in that you see in stories that
you see in Tick Tock you see that in the
Instagram reels as well now they're
clearly different from Instagram stories
yeah Instagram story they did disappear
in 24 hours once you post a real it is
available on Instagram until you delete
it so they are also favored by the
Instagram algorithm yeah which is more
likely to recommend them to people who
don't follow you yes so it is a very
good tool to grow your following but
we'll talk about reels a little later
when we go into the after we've gone
into the advertising on Instagram
so let's look into
um advertising on Instagram here are
some interesting facts about Instagram
advertising each month there are two
million advertisers active on Instagram
yeah so that is a big number of people
the estimated advertising reach for
Instagram users is
1.32 billion users
yes so there and that is an important
one the Instagram
advertising reach has outpaced Facebook
advertising reach in the last year so
and did you know you can reach 22
percent of the global population
age 13 or older in Instagram so a
platform an advertising platform that
you cannot ignore yeah and through
Instagram reels you can reach another
potential audience of close to a billion
people
so an interesting fact to know is that
the split in female and male is about 45
and 55 on the advertising audience for
the Instagram reels
so how do you create Instagram ads
through the Facebook advertising manager
yep and we've done a short or a video
about Facebook advertising in the um in
in an earlier video of this series but
um I'm sure I'm not going to go into
this but I do want to show you a new
feature in the Facebook and Instagram
advertising advertising setup but before
we go into this let's have a quick look
at Instagram and see if we can find some
ads so if I go out of here and I go to
Instagram
yeah so here you see my mobile let's log
in and we're going to Instagram
yeah so by just by browsing through your
news feed you will already come across
ads
yeah so let's see where we see an ad
popping up
so here you see one yes so Shahara
Services official and because it's an ad
you see it's a sponsored ad and here you
see the type of ad that we see here is a
photo ad just one photo that they have
with a call to action in this case visit
the Instagram profile
so here you see an ad yeah which is
again is sponsored but here you see I
can flick through the photo so this is
what we call a carousel ads yeah so
there are multiple photos or in this
case videos so you could also see this
as kind of a video ad but this is a
combination of a video ad and a carousel
ads where you can flick through multiple
photos so what I've done I've saved a
few
um a few ads yeah that is easier so I
don't have to browse so if I click here
on the saved and here you see some ads
yeah so here you see an example of a
photo add but multiple photos and that's
why we also call this a carousel ads
okay here you see an example of us
another Carousel ads yeah so you can see
that it's an ad because it's a sponsored
again multiple photos and a call to
action yeah here you have a photo ad
where it's just one photo and here you
see another Carousel ad with two photos
and here you see a video ads
yeah so these are the ads that you see
on uh in the news feed
besides that there are ads in the
stories and here at the top you see the
stories so let's go here browse through
the stories
so here you see and we immediately see
here a sponsored ad from Barcelona Tanja
yeah and this is a video ad
yeah what I like about the ads on the
stories and that's why they are so
powerful they have a very sort of
natural blend with the stories before
and after them they don't really look
like ads and particularly if you're
making them full screen vertical ads
yeah they blend in very well with the
the with the news feed yeah of the story
feeds yep so here you see another ad
yeah with uh as a story
so you can the call to action are you
looking for the click on the more yeah
and then you can have different more
information in the ad as well so very
powerful
yeah here you see another ad
okay so those are your ads on some uh on
the stories and then here you see the
reels
yeah now
um
yeah but we'll come back to the reels
later and here in the reels you will be
will be able to see and to Showcase your
ads as well
okay so that is the Dosha the ads on um
uh on Instagram yeah so if I summarize
this
yeah if we look at the uh the Instagram
ads
so the first ads that we saw were the
photo or the image ads yeah so
particularly for campaigns where there
is a very strong visual aspect yes
strong visual information that you can
summarize in one single image they are
the best
um for creating image ads these pictures
can be produced using your own
photographers or designs or
illustrations or you can even take an
existing post that you can promote or
that you can boost as an image ad as
well so very straightforward very simple
but the image ads are the simplest way
of creating Instagram ads here you have
a story ads so a story ad multiple
visuals that go in a story engagement is
typically greater with story ads yeah
because it sort of gets the entire
Mobile screen and it's much more
engaging than at in the in the news feed
yep so you see here there is not really
video in there but it is moving kind of
images moving text yeah and audio in
this ad from from Spotify so story ads
are extremely powerful one of the most
popular types of ads in Instagram and
again very easy to create
you don't have to video ads so if you
want to give the viewership more
in-depth look of your brand your
products your services then run a video
ad on Instagram
so make them short you can make them
Square you can make them full full sort
of vertical full screen but the
important thing is try to make the
content engaging
yep and that is where video ads are so
powerful and they can bring a message
across in a very powerful way video ads
on Instagram they are probably the ads
with the highest conversions yeah for um
for people that view the ad and if you
want them to take an action so yep so
those are the video ads and then you
have the reels ads so intermitted with
reels you can have 30 second long ads
that are sort of comparable to story
advertising so they're full screen
vertical videos and again they properly
merge with the organic reels it happened
they have feature they have sound they
feature Sound and Music so very powerful
ads where you can get very good call to
actions learn more learn more buy now
yeah this sort of call to actions that
can really lead people either to drive
them to your website or drive them to
your shop where they can buy your
product
and then we have the carousel ads and
the carousel ads is what I showed you
where you have a collection of photos or
videos that people can swipe through yep
so they can particularly work really
well in your Instagram feed and they are
really good for showcasing multiple
products in your ads what you also see
is that people use Carousel ads where
they have one large sort of horizontal
photo that they split up in three
sections so it is almost like browsing
through the photo from left to right so
very powerful ads that you can get on
them on Google on Facebook and on
Instagram advertising
okay now before we go into the reels
let's go to Facebook ads and show you
some new feature on on the advertising
for the um for Instagram advertising so
here you see the Facebook business
manager yes so it is the meta business
Suite which is sort of a new integrated
platform
um which brings together a number of
functions it used to be the Facebook
business manager but they now have
brought it all under the meta business
Suite so if I go there for my Riad for
Russia page it takes you to everything
you need to do and to plan and to manage
and to track of your Facebook or your
Instagram account yeah you see here I
man can manage the Facebook page and I
can manage the Instagram page now we're
not going to go into the whole of the
method a business suit I just want to
show you the advertising and a new
feature here in advertising if I click
on all tools and then I click here on
ADD
yeah so this is kind of a quick creation
of ads I can automate my ads I can
choose a goal for my ads or I can boost
existing content and I just want to show
you how easy it is these days to make an
ad for your Instagram so if I want to
boost a post
yeah or I can get more leads or whatever
I want to do yeah boost an Instagram
post or real let's go into that
yes so content type I'm just going to do
a post for this sake yeah so we're going
to boost this post
yep and then here you will see how the
ad will look like in your Instagram feed
in this case yep and that's where you
can change the text of your ad so it's a
really good feature to quickly launch an
ad of an existing pouch post make sure
you've got your ads blocker Switched Off
to get access to this yeah you can have
other previews as well
let's see what that will give us
yeah so here you see the feed in
Instagram Explorer here which the
Instagram feed
here which is how it looks in Instagram
stories
here is how it would look in Instagram
reels
yes so really useful tool to quickly see
how your ads will show on Instagram yeah
for an existing post and then of course
you can have the same facilities if you
want to create a new post
okay so that's all I'm going to share
with you on Facebook and Instagram
advertising and how to create your
Instagram ads through the meta business
Suite right so let's go back to the
presentation and let's look at the
Instagram reels so
yeah so where are the reels in Instagram
if I click here on Instagram and then
here is my home
yeah if I click at the bottom on the
little icon here I can then go to reels
and this is exactly like Tick Tock I can
just flick up and that takes me to the
next post
okay so very useful a very simple way of
of creating and sharing content and very
popular way and a lot of people spend
time on the reels to find really cool
content okay so here I can go to the
search and I can search for items so I
can search for instance look at
marketing how to yeah and here you see
books to master marketing which is in a
real format so this is how I can then
access posts in relation to marketing
yeah and and other elements yeah books
to read
yeah so lots of stuff here on the reels
that you can use to find content in
every topic that you're interested in
yep so here is more reels on Morocco
yeah so very useful tool now how do you
create a reel you click on the plus icon
and you basically select here at the
bottom post story real or live you click
real and then you see the four up five
options that you have here for the audio
the length of the video the speed yeah
the grids that you want to change the
scale and there's even a timer so
there's lots of functionality that you
can use here in your
um in developing your video Then by
pressing the center button you can start
recording the video yeah and there is
also opportunities to get
um take for instance do little
characters dancing on your desk yeah or
on your keyboard you can make them
slightly bigger
yeah we lost the character where was he
and now we're recording we've lost so
here's our character I can blow him up a
bit yep and we then see him dancing on
our screen
yeah happy with that stop it do next
yeah I'm gonna not not uh the sticker
here is the video that we've just
created yeah I can edit a clip if I want
to I click next and then I can share it
to Reels I can write a caption I can add
stickers and all the standard stuff that
you can do on your on the reels yeah so
very cool very like Tick Tock and the
the the best thing about it it is so
simple to make it's very intuitive
okay so that is a quick introduction of
the reels
so how do you fit reels into your
digital marketing strategy let's have a
look at that in a bit more um in a bit
more detail yes so it is a really good
way to give your audience a behind the
scenes
overview yes so which works well to get
engagement and to get Trust on your
brand yes so look at the culture in the
company how you make your product how
hard people work look at the the
customer services how they work it's a
really good way to give people a behind
the scenes look of the company and again
to build this brand trust people really
appreciate that yeah so that is one of
the things that you can do with
Instagram reels another very powerful
aspect of Instagram reels is that you
can use it to generate what we call user
generated content why not ask your
customers or your users to create reels
around a topic that you work on yeah and
share it with with a hashtag yes so it's
a great way for people to getting to
know the company getting to know the
products start using influencers yeah
get competitions going where you do
photo contests or maybe video contests
and you can turn those into reels with
the pictures or make them actually let
the user share the the reels they
created themselves yes so sharing user
generated content is a second big
benefit that you can get from using
Instagram reels now Instagram reels
because they're short people have short
attention span they're also really good
to educate your customers yeah or
educate your audience they're a great
way to develop yourself as an expert in
your field by giving their audience
value yeah on how to use your products
how to
um
to to answer questions about your
products yeah on how to do specific
things in in using your products so get
people to learn around your product and
if you make that a recurring type of
real people will come back for them
because they want to learn more about
your products it's also good to see your
products in actions so combined with
user generated content why not ask your
audience yeah your customers to make
short reels on how they use your
products
yes so but if you want to do it yourself
you can really try to highlight what
sets your product apart from your
competition
so yeah you use that to your advantage
in using Instagram reels to highlight
your products and to see your products
in action
and of course it goes without saying if
you make it fun if you make it more
personalized yeah that is a fantastic
way to connect with your audience yep
and that is where children work really
well where pets cats dogs worked really
well try to get casual try to interact
with your followers through very sort of
emotional casual content
so and often what you will see that
these type of reels will have very high
number of views because people just love
to browse through that type of content
yeah create your own challenge or create
your own Trends encourage your fans to
participate and use a special hashtag to
share the content they create yeah for
you
so that's the big benefits that you can
get from the reels yes so use that to
your advantage
good so let's look at some tips and
tricks on Instagram advertising now
remember
most people watch
content on their mobile Instagram is a
mobile app so make sure that you design
your ads with Mobile in mind make sure
that you optimize your ads for mobile
there's nothing worse than seeing a an
Instagram story ads with a horizontal
video and then black above and below yes
so optimize it for the mobile and mobile
is vertical so use that vertical format
because the immersion is better but also
it's much easier to crop a vertical
video to a four by five aspect ready a
ratio or a square ratio than a landscape
video
yes so make sure you design your ads for
mobile first
tip two let the visual speak for
themselves
yeah make your ads less wordy and use
Font sizes that are optimized use color
and make the huge capitals make sure
that it is optimized for mobile devices
use big fonts that stand out use colors
that stand out and that's a visuals
speak for themselves
tip three yeah use animations use Motion
Graphics it is not just video that you
need to have but animated text animated
things happening on the screen they are
videos as well so let the screen come to
life either through video or through
animation and Motion Graphics
and of course very important Keep The
Branding keep the messaging that you
have keep it at the front yeah the first
three seconds people will decide if they
want to watch the entire ad or continue
to scroll yeah so make sure that in the
first three SEC seconds you capture
people's attention and you've put your
branding and your message across
and then of course you sound yeah you
sound in your ads so although a lot of
the people they may want to watch it
without audio Yeah make it accessible by
people with muted volume use trendy
soundtracks to engage those who choose
to listen to your videos
yeah consider using captions as well or
text overlays that's very important if
you have somebody speaking in your ads
yeah always use captions or overlay of
text to make sure that if people have
the sound off that they can still
understand what the ad is all about
right so that is all on the Instagram
ads and the Instagram reels so let's
look at some of the questions that I'm
getting yeah from people when we talk
about Instagram reels and Instagram
advertising so one question I'm getting
a lot is if I do my reels yeah
I didn't get much engagement what should
I do to improve yes so now first of all
in general Instagram reels have a very
high engagement yes so they're probably
the part of Instagram with the highest
engagement that you will see and I will
show you yep so if I go to my Instagram
here on the of my my Riyadh for Russia
let me close this here
yeah so
save the draft close yeah so I'm going
to my Instagram so this is my profile
and here you see my reels now if I post
a video a normal video I used to get
maybe I could I get some views but
nothing like thousands or thousands of
views yes so since we've been using
Instagram reels
yeah we now get views and plays on our
videos here
1244 here is a view 11
000 views of the video
yeah you see 6 000 views of the video
these were numbers we would never get
yeah on the Instagram news feed or the
Instagram stories so here you see you do
get the engagement of your of the reels
on Instagram yeah and it's one of the
big reasons is that Instagram favors the
Instagram algorithm favors reels in your
um yeah in sharing your content okay so
make sure that your video content is up
to scratch maybe the music could be
improved a really good way is to look at
what your competitors are doing
yeah and maybe they do things that
you're not doing so try to learn from
that
okay question two how do I choose to
write soundtrack for my Instagram reels
good question yeah it's very important
that you get the right sound for your
Instagram reels now Instagram has a
whole library of sounds that you can
choose from in creating your uh your
reels Facebook has a huge library of
thousands and thousands of songs that
you can download royalty free and use in
your uh in your posts in your ads yes so
very important first of all is that you
look at what's trending in the world
where when it comes to picking a
soundtrack yes so learn from that what
are the hits at the moment what are the
most popular sound music videos on
YouTube what's the most popular music on
the on Instagram learn from that yep and
then make your decision on what music
you want to use in your video
okay will reels get me organic audience
or do I need to promote them as well
so the beauty about digital marketing is
a duty site what you want to do
yeah whether you just want organic or
whether you want to advertise yeah so
just to be clear for everybody when I
say organic audience it means that if I
do a post without any advertising
how many people will see my post how
many people will see my video my reel
and how many people may like it or share
it
yeah and we know and as I said earlier
the reels have a high
fairly High organic reach from the three
areas in Instagram posts stories and
reels reels gives you the highest
organic reach at the moment but we also
know these days and if you look at some
of my other videos that I posted on
YouTube on digital marketing that social
media is no longer a free right social
media these days is pay to play yeah so
if you really want to use Instagram and
Instagram reels to grow your business to
find leads then you need to combine
organic marketing with paid marketing
yes so start looking into what we call
the pay-per-click advertising and see
how much wider and how much bigger the
audience is that you can Target yep and
then try to invest some money in the
pay-per-click advertising and see what
results you get
so always good to look into that have
your options open but the good thing
about digital marketing you decide what
you want to do in this case
okay and that is it my
um my friends the end of the the session
yeah it's a wrap as we say so a short
introduction to Instagram advertising
and the Instagram reels so if you want
to know more of course check out all the
other Instagram courses that that simply
learn has on our on our YouTube channel
if you like the video please click the
like button and if you want to subscribe
to our Channel click on the Subscribe
button below to join our exciting
Learners community on YouTube that's it
from me now and I will see you at the
next video take care
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here